[Music]
you know every time I'm out in this area
I get a little scared because you know
we got kind of expensive equipment a lot
of people staring at us what's up sir
how you doing man
now if you notice out in East Los
Angeles this is basically what it looks
like and a lot of the dope places that
you can find to eat kind of looks like
this you don't know what the [ __ ]
going on it's like in the back parking
lot of an auto spot also if you're in
East Los Angeles you'll see a lot of
dudes selling I let that in those little
cars and I let those are little creamy
little popsicles super delicious but
we're about to get these delicious tacos
and Vince told me about out here in the
hoods because he wants me to have a good
meal and get rap at the same time just
kidding 11 stellar now usually when I'm
out in Los Angeles and I'm fini for
tacos I usually go to two specific spots
one of them happens to be Avenue 26
which you guys have seen in a previous
video but there are a lot of other taco
spots that are out here that I keep
ignoring and this is a spot that Vince
the camera guy behind his [ __ ] lens
said it's bomb as hell and I've been
looking for tacos that are very similar
especially to of this spot out in San
Diego called what's the call Vince we're
at this spot called cheap Kenny Hotz
eyeshadow but the photos right here
okay well the food came here so anyways
I'm gonna shut the [ __ ] up the first
thing that we grabbed here is the bounty
dough I've actually never had this but
it seems like to be like a toaster
tostada you have like grilled cactus and
beans and whatever like meat that's on
there and they actually had a station
where you can hook it up of course for
me I'm gonna get that what I like to
call a basa moly okay with that red
stuff right there then of course on the
other side I like to get that hot stuff
right here that that roast
yeah roasted hot stuff right there on
that pad tops it off with me uh cilantro
easy now with that same situation that
we had before I got their tacos and
these are actually pretty light beefy
beefy touched and oh and by the way the
two vampiros these three tacos and the
two drinks $17 come on that's enough to
feed two people and it was 17 bucks this
is what I'm talking about you don't need
to spend and drop a lot of money to get
amazing amazing amazing food you guys
don't see me grub at a lot of these like
fancy joints I do but most of the times
if I'm going out to eat I'm eating stuff
like this so my mother who is up just
like into the bedroom so this is the
spread that we have just to go back to
what I was talking about you choose the
meat you get the portions and you dress
it up however you like it I like this
place a lot a lot of like street tacos
spots especially even with these trucks
they don't have people denial and I love
people denial but um we got that
guacamole salsa we got people to dial
cilantro a couple of these tacos so we
have asada which is beef of course oil
which is chicken and they actually have
a grilled chorizo taco here and then you
also have your choice if you want it
with a corn tortilla or flour to you so
let's start with the VAM Piro the lime
look at that crunchy ass dude this is
heavy that grilled cactus that grilled
chicken
then three bucks for this giant thing I
know when you look at it you people
always thinking Quan beads are like your
one is not gonna be enough
this is hefty packed full of flavor its
zesty from the lime that I added to it
and then including the pico de Gaia so
the acid from that and dude that grill
cap is too bro fire and once again they
are using like a grill so this it's
chart it's not like on a skillet just
once again it's good too
something about flames and meat adds
like another depth of flavor that you're
not gonna get I'm just good like a
greased skillet it's not gonna happen
one thing that I forgot to mention about
that Vampiro if you look really close
right here this right here is a grilled
[ __ ] piece of cheese dude are you
[ __ ] kidding me right now are you
[ __ ] are you are you tickling my
butthole right now
I see shades a good next up it's just
corn tortilla I love corn tortillas
flour tortillas are bomb too but right
here
grilled asada oh man
I'm man you guys even call a let me just
get in this real quick show those listen
show show show them show them a stuff
real quick East LA I love you before I
even bite into this I already know that
this is going to be a delicious bite
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah no can I take this real quick
these aren't like small tiny tacos they
hooked it up here and I know we're not
talking about quantity being a good
measure of flavor but I'm telling you
this is delicious like I haven't found a
new travel spot that I've liked it on
while this is promised
[Music]
I love the cactus the grilled cactus is
so [ __ ] good I did not expect that
[ __ ] I haven't seen like a taco joint do
this and it probably is but I haven't
seen its own gotta tried their groceries
though adding this lovely lovely lime to
it like so got a flour tortilla on this
one like I said I don't discriminate
with my tortillas
I like sit corn cuz it's yellow like me
and like a tortilla because it rides me
up Jess
[ __ ] fun man [ __ ] good man chick
alley ha detto and still Mexicali is
what this spot is called I'm memorizing
that's how much I love this spot now man
yo Real Talk this place is the [ __ ]
truth if you don't like this [ __ ]
clearly you have no friends and your
mother dropped you on your head when you
were born you sack of [ __ ]
if you come you kind of bully and [ __ ]
and you don't grow up in like this type
of area it might be a little weird for
you just cuz you're like oh [ __ ] I saw
this stuff in the movies is not that
safe that's fine bro stop being a little
[ __ ] and coming some good [ __ ] food
man good people make great food people
from like real places it's my [ __ ] I
don't know if the other taco spots gonna
be good as this but we've got to find
out
[Music]
my [ __ ] is [ __ ] flies all up in
my house [ __ ]